a report emerged overnight that the
jaguars are talking to the las vegas
raiders about a trade that would send
past russia yannick and gawkway to
nevada and gawkway franchise tagged and
unhappy in jacksonville there was that
twitter war earlier this week between
ngakue and the son of jaguar's owner
shad khan now as this goes and i've
confirmed the talks are happening and
the jaguars are believed to be wanting
too much apparently the raiders are
offering pick number 19 in the draft the
one that they earned last year with
their one loss record and that
the
jaguars want the 12th overall pick the
one that the raiders got from the bears
as part of the khalil mack trade so uh
look i think 12 is way too much
way too much
19 you could argue is too much last year
the chiefs gave up the 29th overall pick
and a second rounder this year to get
frank clark d ford was sent from the
chiefs to the 49ers for a second round
pick this year 19 overall seems like the
right spot now look the jaguars can keep
asking for more and asking for more and
maybe they get more there's no there's
no harm in asking but if if the ultimate
price is the 19th overall pick i think
the jaguars should take that and they
should run with it and that would give
them three first-round picks in this
year's draft i i agree mike i mean
that's just to me a little too greedy
you know first off
you know we know yannick and gawkway
doesn't want to be there so to just sit
there and just go oh okay yeah we want
the 12th pick not the 19th pick i think
that's insane i don't think janik and
gawkway as an all-around football player
is as good as frank clark i don't you
know and and you know yannick and
gawkway jeez i mean you could sit here
and argue whether he was the best pass
rusher on his own football team last
year i mean josh allen was certainly
very impressive impressive their top 10
pick out of kentucky now i don't think
he's as good as janik and gawkway yet as
just a pure
pass rusher that way but man if i'm
jacksonville the 19th pick i'm happy
with that and i'm taking and taking
those three picks in the first round and
man you just have such a great
opportunity to change around your
football team and you know i know
they're trying to say they're not going
to rebuild but they're in a rebuild and
this would speed up that process
exponentially to where you go oh man
jacksonville could be a pain in the butt
this year
let alone like okay no it's only two
years from now so i don't really
understand the the hard line in the sand
there and why they think that yannick
and gawkway would really
even deserve to be traded for the number
12 pick in the nfl draft
and it's amazing when you think that the
raiders had khalil mack they didn't want
to pay khalil mack now they got good
return from the bears for mack but the
idea and this always makes me
uncomfortable when you have a guy who
was
a high producer on your team who was a
great leader a great locker room guy and
he has to get traded somewhere else to
get his financial reward and then you
turn around and you give that financial
reward not exactly the same number of
dollars but pretty damn close to it
presumably if the raiders sign and
gawkway to a long-term deal and it would
be beyond stupid if they trade for him
give up a first round pick for him and
don't sign him to a long-term deal on
the way through the door but the idea of
giving that money to somebody who's
never played for you before that's a bad
message to send to the locker room chris
well it definitely is i mean that that's
understandable uh but still
the locker room understands talent and
especially you know the specialness of
that position the pass rusher position
there's just not a lot of those guys out
there in the nfl there you can just go
man on a week to week basis this guy is
you know he's hell for the other team to
block and the left tackle the block and
he can create problems for us and the
oakland raiders hey listen you know they
kind of swung and missed with their
number four pick last year
cleveland farrell he's a solid football
player but i think they look at him and
go okay yes he's solid football player
we hit a double with that one but we
didn't hit a home run i mean they took
kwell and farrell out of the game
fantastic situations last year like 90
of the time so that tells you a lot
there now the fact that they're in the
market for yannick way yeah they're
looking to have him you know across the
field for max crosby in certain
situations and i'm sure they'll mix mix
and match all these defense ads but mike
i think ultimately it's not as a big
deal in the locker room uh maybe as we
all make it out to be at times because
the players understand the business part
of this
and if this feral career goes sideways
for the raiders man that's going to be a
blow to mike mayhawk the gm of the team
because last year i defended the pick
saying hey the reason why it's a
surprise that the raiders took farrell
at number four is because mike mayok is
no longer part of the media to tell us
that farrell is a guy who should be a
top five pick if you swing and miss on a
guy that no one is really putting in
that stratosphere that really really
delivers a blow to the overall
evaluation skills of the person who made
that selection of feral at number four
overall
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports